so I'm Kyle my background is in user
experience design in front of
development mostly in the biotech space
a little bit in the fintech space
currently in the growth lead at Great
Expectations I've I founded the
developer relations program there I
founded the Great Expectations Community
I've also LED Partnerships with
snowflake for gratifications with
snowflake uh with with Acro astronomer
data bricks and and a bunch of other
tools that you see at uh today
uh so a little bit about your
expectations we have 10 000 members on
slack we have about six well we're
actually just shy so great expectations
I I called my shot I missed it so
congratulations uh uh dot IO slack help
me get there uh we had 6 000
organizations in the community we're
found about 26 different time zones we
have 358 contributors I consider them
all my best friends we have about 9.5
million monthly downloads on Pi Pi and
then our core Persona is a data engineer
also data scientists ml engineer data
analyst data practitioner just someone
who people who care about the quality of
their of their data and people are
curious about this photo I was just
jealous that Maggie had something that
she loved in her photo so this is me
hugging my favorite sandwich
all right so let's get into Partnerships
um Partnerships are good
that's it
all right now
all right does anyone have any good
examples of uh successful Partnerships
it does not have to be in Tech feel free
to yell them out go ahead
excellent
yeah you know we might we might have a
good example later on about that one any
other ones
all right I'll do some of my own so we
have some Classics one or you know ones
that people know we have Uber and Google
we have a map platform you have a taxi
uh app you are enhancing the
functionality of Google by including
this taxi service when you're looking
for directions you're expanding the
reach of uber by getting access to the
Google users uh an absolute classic is
Apple partnering with ATT and Verizon
you have a smartphone you have these
networks to get you on the internet to
make phone calls this is a you know a
fruitful partnership for both
all right so let's get into some more
fun ones here are some in media all
right so we have pink little Kim Maya
and Christina Aguilera for Lady
Marmalade I'm sure everyone knows their
work uh we have Run DMC and Aerosmith uh
so basically what's what's great about
these Partnerships is they're all coming
with their own unique audience and
they're going to be exposing that
audience to one another and expanding
their reach and if you want to think
about it from like maybe a product
analogy they're also uh enhancing their
product by blending genres together and
having almost a new offering so you're
putting together a rock and roll you're
putting together rap and you're you're
creating a new uh a new genre that
people can get excited about uh we have
Looney Tunes and Michael Jordan so this
is going to create a whole new uh
generation of NBA fans and then you're
also going to get more parents to go to
a movie theater to see a cartoon because
I know who might they know Michael
Jordan is something they can get excited
about then you have a classic
partnership you have Godzilla and King
Kong which you know a little bit of a
contentious uh partnership but still a
successful one
all right here's one you probably
never thought about I can probably
guarantee you've never thought about it
uh is KFC and Crocs so what could this
possibly bring this partnership uh so
I'm just going to show you the most
beautiful thing my eyes I've ever seen
we have KFC branded Crocs uh so
apologize for having this up right
before lunch I didn't realize I'd be
doing this but yes when I see someone
walk in Crocs with KFC uh Fried Chicken
on it I'm gonna get hungry and I'm also
probably gonna be pretty jealous about
how comfortable uh they're they are in
those Crocs
all right so uh let's talk about open
source Partnerships
um and uh the beauty of Open Source is
that the tools are are made that like
anyone can contribute to them they're
often extensible and this sets up tools
for Success uh when partnering with for
success for partnering with with other
tools all right so I'm going to use the
most popular slide right now boom there
it is you haven't seen this one before
yes you have you saw in the last
presentation uh so Matrix mad landscape
it just makes it clear that there's not
a one solution fits all you know data
personas out there you have to work well
with others
okay so I'm gonna go into some benefits
of Open Source Partnerships so
extra resources uh by
um partnering with other open source
communities well one when you're
partnering with another tool you get the
extra resources of subject matter
Experts of that other Tool uh but then
if you when you work in open source
communities you get the power of those
communities
so what this does is it helps you find
and solve big complex problems faster
because these communities have more
access to you they have the ability to
publish their issues and ability to also
solve their own issues and this is going
to be working outside of your
development cycle uh you know you do
have to review you do have to accept
these PRS make sure it makes sense for
your tool but that engineering work can
happen outside
also you know your maintenance could go
down when people are take real ownership
over their contributions uh you'll find
people that will do lots of different
bug fixes and and then a classic
contribution is fixing typos just to be
to be a contributor uh which I'm not
complaining about because I you might
even find a typo here I could use my own
contributor for typos
all right moving along uh increase reach
uh so you're going to increase your
reach like you know like we said in
those other examples by exposing
yourself to other audiences but what's
interesting is you might expose yourself
to different use cases that your tool
doesn't have yet or even new markets uh
so there can be that contributor that
comes around they see your tool and they
go oh wow this is close enough to my use
case I'm going to be that key
contributor that gets it there so then
when the next person comes around it's
more likely that they're going to adopt
your product
um a good example oops a good example of
this for us is um we Great Expectations
started more in the healthcare focusing
on Health Care problems so there are
lots of tests for your data for for
healthcare and then some people from the
financial industry came around and were
like oh wow you could test your data
the tests don't quite fit for us yet so
we're going to contribute some tests so
the next person that comes around it's
in that industry is more likely to adopt
and uh a good a real example is uh
Capital One is one of our biggest
contributors they contributed a bunch of
tests around credit card validation and
security so now in that next company
comes around that offers a type of
service they're going to be more likely
to adopt uh and by expanding your
community by partnering with other
communities you can get more
opportunities to find those people that
are going to help uh fill out your
product for for that use case
so enhanced functionality
think about the Uber and Google Maps uh
you know this was pretty straightforward
the Uber and Google Maps you have the
map platform you have the taxi platform
uh does does Google want to make their
own taxi platform and and complete
compete with Uber that tool that already
has product Market fit full
functionality or do they want to just
adopt it onto their platform so they
enhance their functionality
okay increase credibility uh as a
product and as a player in the space
this is where you get real momentum uh
by by succeeding in these Partnerships
you're going to get more Partnerships
but something that's important to point
out is that you have to give line a
sight to how someone's going to
accomplish this so have good
documentation have content out there
that shows how people were successful in
integrating whether it was a Community
member or if it was a product that you
partnered with so that people could see
it's possible you're bound to get more
inbound interest if people can see how
they'll get from A to B uh uh otherwise
there's a contribute you have to find
some really courageous people to help
you accomplish that that goal
um so our goal here is to have you guys
walk away with like a clear road map of
why you do it who you do it with and how
you get it done so let's talk about the
people right we know why this is
important but who are the players here
so your community may look a little bit
like this or it may look a little bit
like this equally fantastic equally
powerful
mutants or otherwise we love it but
there are two kind of personas that we
think about regardless of how big your
community is the type of people that
show up whether you're a core
maintaining team is huge or maybe it's a
couple of people there are a couple of
roles for us to kind of represent in
this collaboration process
so first and foremost is going to be our
community or product manager this may
not actually be your your official role
but you're standing in as the person to
interface directly with the community
and also do a lot of that problem
Discovery so your goals here are one
growing your community you also want to
gain that credibility and you want to
expand your product functionality either
with your own resources and other
communities resources or people within
your own community
so we go about this with a few different
things one is and this is the most
important just being deeply connected
with the people who are in your
community talking to them asking them
questions what problems are they facing
how are they actually using the current
open source project in their own
environment what's going well what isn't
going well but really just kind of tying
back the problem space to the people
within your own community
the other thing is you want to make sure
that your collaboration process is
seamless so by the time that people
you're working with people who are going
above and beyond and contributing back
to something for their greater good so
it better be pretty damn easy for them
to do that
um so just real clear documentation
about the kind of Rules of Engagement
who you should work with what that looks
like I have a rune in the audience is
one of the top contributors of data Hub
and so I'm glad to see that we can make
those things happen
um and then the other thing is you know
even if you're not a technically a
product manager bring in that product
hat and help guide those decisions
around design trade-offs resolving
blockers and really just making sure
that again when people are showing up to
build you just you're helping them do
the damn thing
last but not least you got to celebrate
the people we're all about the people
but so this is uh really giving people a
shout out helping them feel valued and
also kind of just building out their own
network as well so let's talk about who
those Builders are these are going to be
contributing Engineers so these could be
folks that are on your own team right so
maybe you're actually maintaining the
repo or the project itself or are there
folks within your own Community or their
folks within another Community but these
are folks that are going to be motivated
by saving money by spending their own
time so there's a mill I mean we saw
the diagram of all the tools right
there's a tool for every problem we
could ever dream of but those all cost
money so the open source solution is a
great way to save the money but kind of
invest on the actual implementation side
these folks are also going to be
motivated by making sure that these
projects fit really nicely within their
existing stack so it can be a really
seamless integration there and then of
course they also want to build their
Professional Network so we see this
being done by
contributing back to projects so kind of
what Kyle said seeing something that
maybe fits your use case maybe 80
percent in contributing back to get it
to that hundred percent they're going to
be collaborating really closely with you
so you're building a really close
partnership and then
um they're building out their own
network and their own kind of uh Rapport
of being a subject matter expert and so
you want to make sure that you're giving
them the tools to do that be successful
there
so you have your community there's
another Community you've identified your
players now it's time
to partner up people we got to make it
happen
so we've talked about why we collaborate
we talk about who the people are let's
break it down into a few different
phases we're going to break these into
four different steps I'm going to go
through this pretty quickly but then we
have a couple of case studies to
demonstrate how we've done it in action
so
first and foremost Discovery this is
where you're the community manager the
product manager and you're working
directly with folks in your community to
understand what problems are out there
um and also really taking the time to
identify is this a problem that we're
best suited to solve or are there other
communities or tools that are doing it
well and you want to do Outreach there
to kind of bridge that Gap
once you've identified your problem
space you want to actually start
planning it of course scope it out and
this is also a critical stage where you
are getting feedback early and often
from your own community so that you know
what you're building why you're building
it and you have that work really cleanly
scoped
of course during your development you
have this is where your engineer is
coming in again this could be someone
who's on your maintaining team it could
be someone from your community or
another Community but basically you're
building it out getting it tested and
don't forget your documentation don't
forget it's part of the product
and then last but not least this is
critical
um really have a clear strategy around
your promotion again to help people
understand kind of how things came to be
how they can use it and also how they
can contribute
so four steps easy right I know that it
can feel like a lot what we continue to
see time and time again is once you do
this kind of one time through it can
feel like a little bit of a drawn out
process especially in a world where
we're all trying to be as agile as
humanly possible but there's a really
fascinating flywheel that happens that
once you establish that pattern folks in
the community know how to kind of like
lather rinse and repeat and that
flywheels kind of starts to take on its
own identity with other people in the
community driving it
so we're going to walk through a couple
of examples
and Kyle's going to start it off please
don't please don't it's okay
all right we did we didn't explode
[Music]
all right um I'm going to go through a
uh example here
all right so I'm gonna talk about the
partnership between astronomer and Great
Expectations
um I really think this partnership was
was destined to happen uh airflow helps
you manage all the tasks you want to run
organize in a way that reflects their
relationship Independence dependencies
represented as a dag and Great
Expectations is a tool that ensures the
data you're managing in that dag is as
expected through tests or expectations
uh for companies who want to send their
data from A to B with confidence this is
a match made in heaven
so I'm going to just quick value of
Great Expectations uh through one of my
favorite data horror stories so a
perfectly healthy person uh moves from
Europe to the US and their insurance
bill skyrockets well this is because
they went from being 1.8 meters tall
it's about six feet and 180 pounds to
1.8 feet tall and 180 pounds uh so the
hell you know the insurer is curious of
why this person's still alive and yes
we're going to send you a massive bill
because you're you're a huge risk and
then that other per and the person on
the other end is uh going to become a
very sad Warrior when they get this
massive bill in there so like healthcare
is already hard uh let's you know stop
these mistakes from happening uh before
before they happen so we don't get these
sad warios
all right so back to the relationship
between Great Expectations and
astronomer uh so astronomer has worked
very closely with their customers to
build broad data platforms around Apache
airflow uh while working on data quality
and and and validation layer of their
data platforms they know it's a training
request that people were asking to use
Great Expectations but they also had
questions around best practices in using
these two tools together and just around
data quality in general so this led to
the astronomer team reaching out to us
uh so we were we were really excited
about about this oh I think I popped
ahead there
oh
so we were we were really excited about
this uh potential partnership uh and
willing to invest resources in it which
is you know one of the benefits of a
partnership uh and uh this started uh
the discussion on coming up with best
practices around leveraging Great
Expectations and Apache airflow and and
this this could have just been content
uh and that would have been a great
partnership to do together uh but upon
further discussion it was clear that
creating the Great Expectations airflow
provider made a lot of sense uh so from
there we planned the work uh we kept the
interested community members in the loop
for feedback and early testing uh some
of these community members also became
key contributors uh to the project and
uh soon enough we released Great
Expectations uh airflow provider uh you
could see this now on the astronomer
registry we completed this in about it
was around 2020 like early 2020 uh and
now it gets 380 000 uh downloads per
month uh so the momentum kept building
it's been really successful and I'll go
over sort of how we got how we got there
so once the integration was complete we
announced the integration to our
community uh and we published the the
documentation uh so here you'll see the
documentation published on our
respective websites make sure to link to
each other that's going to help that
cross community growth
um and then my recommendation is with
the release of the documentation and uh
you know what it the the product that
you're putting out is to also have uh
hello world blogs so this content is
really friendly to share and people who
want to spread news uh are going to are
going to enjoy these pieces of content
uh to be able to be able to share it
also gives you the opportunity to shout
out uh people in the community that made
that made things happen uh so you know a
shout out to Brian Lavery Nick betham
book neither stick and then on the
astronomer team Peter Joy was a big part
of it and then on our side Sam Bell was
a massive part of of making making this
happen
so
one great thing about this announcement
in the Hello World blog is now you can
start to monitor your community for
early adopters uh this is an important
part to get that early feedback to learn
about the use cases that people are are
applying your your tool to there will be
bugs and this is a good way to find them
them quickly so some good good QA
uh and then uh usually what we do uh is
uh usually what we do is we will set up
a community event a few weeks out maybe
a month out uh so you can learn from
those early adopters you can maybe fix
some bugs before the community event but
then also gives time people time to
think about the integration so you're
not just laying it on them at the event
and then they have to come back like
you're not going to get good questions
that way you'll get much better
questions if you have if people have
time to think about it read the material
and use it themselves
so doing all this promotion doing the
events doing the blogs uh sharing on
your social media hopefully what this
leads to is other people picking it up
um so you know we were it worked out for
us people picked up uh the news of of
the integration I mean it's people's
jobs to do this so give them give them
something to share and and sure enough
you'll get you'll get some some momentum
uh so I talked about community events a
little bit uh these are two recordings
from community events that we did in our
respective communities so this is a
great way to sort of get a spike of
growth in your community uh they hosted
us we hosted them uh when you go to the
other person's uh Community event you
get to sort of share your expertise and
give them an opportunity to come to your
community to learn more about what you
can provide so for us when we're at the
astronomer uh uh you know after we do
the demo of the provider you if you want
to learn more about data quality if you
want to learn more about how to use your
expectations come to our slack read our
documentation you'll get a good spike in
growth and then you're also giving
people an opportunity to have a better
user experience on the on the
integration uh so I want to pop out I
want to point out this bottom event a
little bit different so this is you know
also go like if you can get into
different conferences
um and you can get awesome recordings
like this that's great but this is also
an example of sort of an elevated did
piece of content where you bring in a
third party so again works well with
others works well across the the whole
stack so for here we have which was a
good a good marketing one it's called
the dagstack uh DBT airflow Great
Expectations uh Sam Bell did a great job
promoting this all around and we were
able to bring in that third party one
you get extra signal boosting two we
picked the good tool to get uh some some
exposure of course and we did it at
coalesce but also what's really great
about this third party is that it gives
people the end to end more end-to-end
experience of where your tool fits so
you know your data is going from A to B
you're testing with your expectations
and then you can you can uh build your
models in in DBT so someone go oh I get
it like this is where your tool fits in
my in my whole experience
uh okay so um rounding it out uh so from
here this is talking about that flywheel
part of when the community picks it up
um you we did all the promotion people
are very aware about it people are
excited about it they're using it and
now they're starting to enhance the
offering uh so that momentum is going to
continue to build and you're going to
want to make sure that you feel you feed
that that uh that that flywheel so as a
community manager from you know if I put
my community manager hat on I would say
one of the biggest uh piece of advice I
can give is having a positive feedback
loop a positive feedback loop means that
when someone does something good in your
community you shout that out in in
different ways uh it does two things one
it shows that you appreciate your
community members it'll encourage that
person to do more work but then it shows
other people that it's possible to do um
if if people don't see these
contributions happening maybe they won't
be encouraged to do it themselves so
this will start to build on on top of
itself when you when you provide that
positive feedback loop uh an example
great example is uh Benji lampel from
the astronomer team did a Blog about how
the people at factory pal pal made some
great contributions to the provider so
this blog goes out uh you don't have to
leave the blogs for every contribution
every little thing but shout outs go a
long way both in social media in your
community channels send some swag
um you know it's it's going to pay
dividends
all right so just to wrap this up uh
this was a great partnership total home
run it continues to pay dividends for
both sides uh from a partnership
perspective it checked the boxes we we
increase the reach we enhance
functionality uh and we saved Resources
by partnering with uh community members
and the other team and it improved our
credibility and to take my own advice
shout out to Pizza Joy Sam Bell and book
Knitter stick was one of the early
contributors to
all right
seamless handoff done
all right so Kyle did a really great job
of talking us through an example of
cross community collaboration I'm going
to take a little bit more of a nuanced
look at how you can collaborate within
your own Community by adopting other
open source tools but without kind of
needing to do a bunch of that additional
facilitation with another community
not to say that you shouldn't but it's
just an option right so this is a
partnership with a company in the data
Hub community called grab
um before we dig into that I want to
give you a little bit of extra context
about what data Hub is doing just to set
it up a little bit better
um I think we should turn maybe this is
like a drinking game like we have to
take a shot every time this slide comes
up
what's funny is that he and I both added
this slide without knowing the other
person did and so like we're just really
we're abusing it sometimes we did it
twice yeah exactly so um
we are familiar with this as data
practitioners we know that our landscape
is very complex uh it's a lot to
navigate this makes onboarding new team
members really difficult it makes
getting your stakeholders bought in
really difficult and it requires a huge
mental map or a mental model of how all
of these things fit together
so datahub offers an open source
solution for metadata management kind of
the single plane of glass over all of
your data tools so you can search and
discover regardless of what platform
what tool you're looking at so it could
be a looker chart a tableau dashboard
airflow dag it could be a mongodb data
data set whatever the whatever the
technology we make it really easy to
Plug and Play so you can not only one
search and discover but also move on
towards governing your data and making
sure that you're doing things
the data practitioner way I don't know
that doesn't mean anything but you know
what I mean another piece of it is we do
a really great job of automatically
extracting lineage so you can see the
full end-to-end life cycle of your data
regardless of where it started or where
it's transformed or consumed you can
spend more time kind of debugging data
issues as they come up and spending less
time like my man Charlie this is me for
2016 to 2018 while I was Tech lead of a
data team I was constantly trying to map
out
all of the things anywhere so
data hub's a great tool for us to start
servicing those complexities but it's
also a platform that's built by data
platform Engineers or software Engineers
for other folks and not quite
necessarily doing a great job just yet
of bringing in less technical uh users
so even though we're doing a great job
of surfacing up with the complexity
we're kind of missing a key stakeholder
in that equation so
cut back to our community collaboration
we had folks from the grab team come to
us and say hey we're getting some
feedback that as we roll this out to our
stakeholders the
um the process of documenting or
enriching some of these core data
entities is really really
counter-intuitive and also intimidating
to them
so if we take a quick look this is an
example of the old editing experience
for folks that are used to working in
markdown this is actually probably a
really great experience because you have
the rendered markdown on the right right
but for folks who have never heard of
markdown I my favorite piece of feedback
I've ever gotten was someone looked at
this and said it looks like it was built
in the 90s
and I loved that right because it's like
really valid feedback but you know
you're not talking we weren't talking to
the right people or building for the
right people
so with this in mind the grab team set
basically came to us and said hey we're
going to be building this solution with
within our own Fork but do you want to
like we can we can contribute it back as
well
so of course that was something where as
kind of like the PM or the community
manager uh from that lens I have to
think about how do we minimize the
amount of engineering effort or like
risk that we take on without kind of
knowing if this is the right thing to
build and also my own team is already
stretched incredibly thin we have 15
different deadlines like there's a ton
going on so this is a great opportunity
for us to say cool if you can drive it
we'll support you along the way
so in the planning process we came
together we had folks from my team to
kind of act as
um
kind of like guides in the contribution
process and help kind of make some of
those assigned decisions but we came
together and kind of established our
kind of key criteria so first and
foremost of course it needed to be open
source we are an open source platform we
can't Implement something that people
will suddenly need to pay for uh it's
just not gonna work
um just from a functionality standpoint
the end users wanted to make sure that
they could tag and Associate entities to
one another so if you're documenting
something maybe you want to like at a
person and say this is the expert here
or this relates to this other entity
um the other thing is that we wanted it
to be really seamless to upload images I
don't know how many times you guys have
written out hyperlinks for images and
markdown not a fun experience that's I
get the brackets versus parentheses
wrong every time
um but then the biggest kind of
functional requirement was that we
needed to make sure that we were moving
away from that markdown first experience
I wanted to uh in In The Biz which I
didn't know it's called what you see is
what you get editor so that's what we
wanted to move towards
um so as we're talking through this as a
team both teams from
um my core maintaining team the team
from grab we're all hypothesizing that
as long as we have a migration strategy
it'll be easy for like we could just
migrate away from markdown store and
text into Json or whatever the format it
needed to be for whatever we picked up
but there was something in my mind I was
like maybe we should validate this maybe
we should talk to people right so this
is where we start to bring in our
community as early as possible before we
actually start building anything
so I sent out this poll
um to literally everybody in the
community and I'm anticipating like no
one's going to answer this no one knows
what we're talking about also who cares
if we're storing in markdown we'll be
able to migrate it whatever we had 120
people respond to it it was one of the
most highly responded surveys I'd ever
I'd sent out to at that time and the
overwhelming majority was please do not
take away markdown support we've built
out some really Advanced ways of using
it these really nuanced use cases that
ultimately like we would have just kind
of shrugged off and ruined the
experience for a ton of people and and
broken
um how they were adopting the tool so
that informed our uh our design
requirements or our tool our open source
tooling choice
which
moved us into the development phase
where we ultimately went with an open
source framework called re-mirror again
this is enough this is an example of
where we are actually building this
cross-community collaboration without
needing to do a bunch of kind of like uh
facilitation or a lot of like uh maybe
unnecessary work to get it done right
like we can work we can work on our own
and build it out and make it successful
there
so at the end of this
we end up with so this is what we had
before now we end up with this really
nice what you see is what you get
experience for folks who are used to
working in Wiki tools like maybe notion
or Confluence or I mean I'll even like
Google Docs this is a really intuitive
experience for them it's stored in
markdown on the back end that the front
uh the the user has no idea of that
right so we also totally Advance the
functionality of this we now have syntax
highlighted code blocks that are much
easier to work with we also have tables
how many times do you want to like build
a table in markdown again nightmare
um and also now the the ability to start
tagging other entities
um or other folks within the
organization
so now we are still actively in our
promotion phase
um we the way that we've approached this
is uh so far as twofold one by
um making sure that we're giving like a
ton of shout outs within our slack
praising or like uh having full-on
walk-throughs during our uh Town Hall
sessions and
um just over the next couple of months
we'll start moving into kind of like the
blog posts and the more curated here's
how you do it here's why we did it Etc
um I
had an absolute Joy working with Amanda
and Harvey from the grab team they
showed so much dedication and just like
came and drove the show it was
absolutely incredible
um
and there was something else that I was
going to say that I forgot oh no now I
remember
um what's really also really amazing
from this is that since we started
communicating to folks that we went
through this process in the matter of a
month I've spun up three additional
community-led processes or like
workflows just like this because people
understand that it's possible and they
have kind of like a run book or like a
framework to work within so it's really
going to escalate how quickly we can
start to solve really hard problems it's
going to elevate the people in our
community and also open up more
opportunities for us to work with other
communities as it comes
thank you
all right uh so to wrap this up uh what
are the what are the benefits you get
extra resources you increase reach you
enhance functionality and you're going
to increase the credibility as a product
and as a player in the space how do you
accomplish it you go through your
discover phase you're paying attention
to the community you're planning phase
your development phase your promotion
phase and that'll lead towards that
Community uh flywheel that will build on
what on What You've what you've done uh
but if you're just gonna remember one
thing
like I said I probably could have
stopped on the third slide partnership's
good
that's it thank you very much
[Music]